da sind wir wieder zwei Tage vor dem
wm-showdown gegen Spanien mein
persönlicher Tipp achten Sie mal drauf
als Zeichen für die Menschenrechte wird
Hansi Flick wie schon gegen Japan
gnadenlos jeden Auswechseln der zu gut
spielt
und das FIFA so dazu später mehr jetzt
aber erstmal was heiteres zum
gemeinsamen abschmunzeln die
Haushaltsdebatte im Bundestag diese
Woche mit starredner Christian Lindner
zum Thema kreative Buchführung ja da
kennen sie aus ne sie wissen ja keiner
denkt sich so schöne Namen für neue
Schulden aus wie unser Chrissi
Sondervermögen nach wie vor reinste
Poesie und dann hat der Mann auch noch
Zeit sich solche Sex hier zu schreiben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Koalition hat einen Bundeshaushalt
aufgestellt der die Schuldenbremse
achtet
ja der war gut oder ja nicht falsch
verstehen die Regierung muss in dieser
Krise natürlich gigantische Schulden
machen logisch aber man könnte sie auch
mal so nennen und wir sollten schon was
rauskriegen fürs viele Geld finde ich
zum Beispiel eine Bundeswehr die in der
Lage ist und ich weiß das klingt jetzt
irre das Land im Ernstfall regelrecht zu
verteidigen sehr gut oder ich fände
schön ja ähm tatsächlich hat sich da
aber seit der legendären Zeitenwende
Rede von Olaf Scholz im Februar nicht
wirklich was getan wie man hört jedes
Jahr mehr als zwei Prozent vom
Bruttoinlandsprodukt für Verteidigung
das war das Versprechen das Kanzlers so
im nächsten Jahr werden es
1,6
und sorry aber da steht Scholz
persönlich in der Verantwortung der gibt
die Richtung vor und ohne diese Bilder
von Mittwoch überbewerten zu wollen das
mit dem die Richtung finden
ist eventuell nicht so sein Ding
ja
2023 singt der reguläre wer Etat sogar
leicht sinkt wo Du uns nicht erzählt wir
werden jetzt eine militärische
Führungsmacht deswegen deswegen haben
doch neulich beim G20-Gipfel alle so
Hilfe suchen zum world leader Olaf
geguckt sie wissen das berühmte Foto zum
Hintergrund
da war gerade die Rakete in Polen
eingeschlagen und der erste Verdacht
viel natürlich wie immer auf Deutschland
ne
ja jemand sieht das auf dem Foto alles
so Olaf
nee diesmal nicht ehrlich
ist die wahre Geschichte tatsächlich
fehlt beim Bund noch so einiges zum
Beispiel hier wie heißt das noch was man
braucht damit man das Gewehr im Kampf
nicht werfen muss Munition genau ja
unsere Bundeswehr hätte im Ernstfall
Munition für nur einen oder zwei
Kampftage maximum ja die NATO verlangt
aber 30 und der Witz ist ausgerechnet
Patronen also das was wir am aller
trinksten brauchen dürfen aus dem
Sondervermögen nicht bezahlt werden
allein dafür bräuchten wir bis 2030 laut
Experten 20 Milliarden da fällt mir ein
heute ist doch Black Friday
da könnte Lindner einfach bei Amazon auf
die neue Kategorie
schattenhaushaltswaren gehen ja da gibt
es alles du kriegst alles 10.000 Schuss
Munition da geht's Windräder für die
Energiewende Thermomix eine
gaspreisbremse was man braucht bei der
Bezahlfunktion wählt man zwischen
Schattenhaushalt Sondervermögen oder
Doppelpunkt super easy und das geilste
die Rechnung zahlen nicht wir sondern
viel später unsere Kinder
[Applaus]
ja nicht heulen Geld verdienen
Verteidigungsministerin Christine
Lamprecht verweigert übrigens zum Thema
Munition im Bundestag die Aussage sie
will dazu nicht sagen sonst bestünde die
Gefahr das und ich zitiere sie
Einzelheiten über die Arbeitsfähigkeit
der Bundeswehr bekannt wird
ich fürchte die sind schon bekannt
wenn wir schaffen es ja nicht mal den
Soldaten die wir nach Mali schicken
Hosen zu kaufen ist kein Spaß die
kriegen jetzt alle Sonnenbrand in der
Kniekehle ohne Hemd und ohne Hose nach
Mali von fehlenden Großgeräten mal ganz
zu schweigen sie werden bestimmte
Systeme nicht einfach beim Baumarkt aus
dem Regal rausholen können also jetzt
mal im ernst
also ich kaufe meine Haubitzen immer
beim Obi
ja stehen direkt neben dem Holzzuschnitt
natürlich gibt sie nicht im Baumarkt hat
auch keiner behauptet langsam
beschleicht einen der schlimme Verdacht
Christine Lambrecht ist vielleicht doch
nicht die ideale Besetzung für ihren Job
ja die Industrie die Waffenindustrie hat
ja im Sommer explizit Angeboten mehr
Munition schneller zu produzieren keine
Antwort und jetzt wurde sie auch noch
von einem Gericht gezwungen zu verraten
wer das berühmte Foto von ihrem Sohn
damals im Hubschrauber gemacht hat
Überraschung kommen sie nie drauf sie
selber
aber bitte nicht posten Schätzchen ich
verlasse mich auf dich ich sage die
Bundeswehr hat besseres verdient jetzt
machen sich schon Streaming-Dienste über
uns lustig
unsere Bundeswehr eine schlagkräftige
Truppe mit der man sich besser nicht
anlegt doch sie hat ein dunkles
Geheimnis die Patronen reichen nur für
zwei Tage jetzt bei Netflix das große
Remake des legendären Anti kriegsfilms
im Westen nichts Neues zum Nachladen
erschreckend realistische Bilder zeigen
deutsche Panzer die zwar fahren aber
nicht mehr schießen das ist egal
Hauptsache ich höre Roland Kaiser
[Musik]
was muss diese Truppe noch ertragen
sehen Sie quälendlange Szenen in denen
ein Abteilungsleiter im
Verteidigungsministerium kurz überlegt
Munition zu bestellen es dann aber doch
nicht macht weniger Action geht gar
nicht im Westen nichts Neues zum
Nachladen mit Philipp Amthor als Sohn
der Ministerin Veronika Ferres als
kaputte Panzerhaubitze ohne Ersatzteile
und zum ersten Mal Thomas Gottschalk als
Christine Lambrecht jetzt ein Netflix
aber nur für zwei Tage
[Applaus]
Munition für zwei Tage dann Capitulation
wie es aussieht aber andererseits
kapitulieren ist ja neuerdings eh unser
Ding ich sag nur One Love Bünde ja die
FIFA befehlt Binde Weg zack nehmen wir
die ab ja weil sonst kriegt unser Manu
neu vielleicht eine gelbe Karte oder
weiß nicht ganz doll schimpfe das können
wir nicht riskieren erbärmlich ja wie es
aussieht wird Deutschland in Katar kein
Titel holen aber dafür sind wir jetzt
schon Weltmeister in große Fresse nichts
dahinter
man kann es natürlich die Binde nehmen
ja aber die Werte für die wir stehen die
werden wir haben und die werden auch
immer wieder zum Ausdruck bringen
sie können uns die Binde nehmen und wir
werden auch in Zukunft alles machen was
diese aber wir finden es nicht gut
Bierhoff ey ja gut dafür hat er jetzt
neuen Trikots von unserem Land gezogen
kleiner Feigling das finde ich okay
ja aber warum warum haben Sie nicht mehr
riskiert was hätte denn im schlimmsten
Fall passieren können
Punktabzug wir haben doch gar keine
Punkte
abgesehen davon hat Herr Bier auf ja
selber mehrmals gegen Menschenrechte
verstoßen dann istane von Danone
davon krieg ich nie genug
[Musik]
ja ich schon
warum hat er sich damals nicht den Mund
zugehalten fragt man sich der dänische
Fußballverband denkt über einen Austritt
aus der FIFA nach warum denken wir da
nicht mal mit ja austreten und einfach
eine eigene kriminelle Organisation
Gründen wo ist das Problem oder wollen
wir uns diesen Irrsinn hier noch lange
gefallen lassen Belgien muss den
Schriftzug love Liebe von der Innenseite
des Kragens seines Auswärtstrikots
entfernen oh mann ja Love ist einfach zu
politisch
erlaubt denke ich mal ich persönlich und
da bin ich ein bisschen stolz drauf habe
es bisher übrigens geschafft noch kein
einziges Spiel zu gucken wirklich
aber ich habe natürlich auch jemand der
das für mich macht für Geld Friedemann
Weise
Videobeweise mit Friedemann Weise was
für eine Woche in Katar wir werden uns
alle für immer daran erinnern wo wir
waren als man uns die Binde nahm diese
Armbinde die sorgt heute für ziemlich
viel Ärger es geht um diese Binde hier
die One Love armbindet diese One Love
Kapitänsbinde in dieser Kapitäns diese
Binde diese Binde die wir hier sehen
genau diese Freiheit die man auch
während der Regel haben möchte
Freiheit während der Regel sie meint
Freiheit während der WM aber wegen der
Regel der FIFA wurde sie dann doch nicht
getragen den katharis war die Message
One Love einfach zu beschränkt der
E-Mail von Katha hat alleine schon drei
Frauen kein Witz da ist eine Liebe nicht
genug und die Mannschaft hat ja dann
doch noch ein Zeichen gesetzt und zwar
für die Verlängerung der maskenpflicht
in Regionalbahn das war nicht leicht für
das Team die Spieler sind da ja in einem
System in dem Menschen Angst davor haben
müssen sich als schwul zu outen und dann
mussten sie auch noch nach Katar
inzwischen wenden sich schon die ersten
Sponsoren ab der Handelsriese Rewe mit
Sitz in Köln hat seine Zusammenarbeit
mit dem Deutschen Fußball-Bund gestoppt
okay der Vertrag lief eh Ende des Jahres
aus aber egal das war keine billige
PR-Aktion da ging es um Haltung die
haben sogar ihr Sortiment umgestellt
jetzt bei Rewe an der Fleischtheke die
Olli Bierhoff gesichtswurst ohne Mund
und der
dfb-rehrücken ohne Rückgrat der
schimmert sogar in Regenbogenfarben wenn
man ihn lang genug liegen lässt mein
Gott wie schön war dagegen damals der
Auftakt zu unserer WM 2006 aber wir sind
ja auch ein modernes offenes Land und
belästigt dich die ganze Welt mit
unseren komischen Traditionen
[Musik]
früher hießen sie Wolfs aus Leute ja
früher hießen sie Wolfs aus Leute und
davor hießen sie Deppen die sich Glocken
auf die Nüsse hauen
am Ende läuft alle Kritik an der WM auf
FIFA Chef Infantino hinaus extra aus der
Schweiz nach Katha gezogen und steuern
um die Welt zu einem besseren Ort zu
machen und das obwohl er es selbst als
Kind so schwer hatte also teilt als cool
so rote Haare und Sommersprossen endlich
sagts mal einer es gibt Diskriminierung
wegen sexuelle Orientierung wegen Alter
Herkunft Religion und Kritik an der
Regierung das alles will ich nicht
bestreiten doch es gibt Menschen die
noch mehr leiden
keiner hat so schwer wie ein roter Regen
ja keiner hat so schwer wie ein
rothaariger mit 2,7 Millionen
Jahresgehalt und keinem einzigen roten
Haaren
so und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe Fans der feinsten Unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere Videos
sehen wollt
super take wir haben es ich sehe auch
echt schick aus heute